>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Karen Lloyd: Good morning.
I want to thank each of you
for taking the time to come
to the most beautiful
building in Washington DC
but most especially, to the
Coolidge Auditorium to be a part
of our Veterans Day programming.
As direct I'm Karen Lloyd
and I'm the director
of the Veterans History Project,
and as a retired army aviator
I'm also the widow, sibling
and child of veterans.
And I'm so pleased to welcome
you, especially the veterans,
to the Library of Congress.
The library makes a special
effort this week in particular
to honor and recognize
veterans and their families
and to explore the ways military
men and women have connected
to home and family during
and after their service
for World War I through
the current conflicts.
We are proud to collaborate
with our colleagues
from across the library to
offer a series of events titled:
Coming Home Veterans Day
at the Library of Congress.
In the back, you will
find his handy card --
With all of today's
programming's,
many of which airline
to are exhibited
echoes of the Great War.
This exhibit examines the
upheaval of the World War
as Americans confronted it,
both at home and abroad.
It's located up here in
the Jefferson building
and its compellingly
rendered offers glimpses
of The Human Condition
Transcendence of Time and Place,
in part three over
30 collections
from the Veterans
History Project.
I hope you'll find
time to see it.
I'd also ask that you
consider taking a copy
of not just this library
magazine, but also the other one
that we have in the
back as you depart.
It focuses in part
on The Veterans History
Project and our collections.
Now, a little bit about The
Veterans History Project:
it provides inspiration
and instruction
to foster nationwide volunteer
effort for individuals to reach
out to the veterans and their
lives and listen really listen,
and sending donate those
collections to the library,
so that we have those
oral histories
and first-person narratives.
From World War I through the
current conflict Veterans
like Mr. Greenwall whose
family graciously donated his
interviews with the
Veterans History Project
and whose words come alive,
both through the exhibit
and through this morning's
Porter Ale by Douglas Taurel.
After the performance,
both Douglas
and our senior reference
specialist Megan Harris will
answer your questions.
So, again thank you for
joining us joining us today
and a special shout-out
to the Greenwall family
who made a special effort
to come today and we are
so appreciative of that.
So, thank you [applauses].
[ Music ]
?? Douglas Taurel: In
1917, milk was 36 cents,
a loaf of bread was 9 cents
and the average yearly
income of a man $6.50.
That's what I made in
my shop, me and Leah;
we have a nice shop
in 22 E-70 Street.
We sold candles,
hydrate candles,
[inaudible] barbers supplies,
tobacco, good tobacco.
On April 2nd 1917, our president
Woodrow Wilson stood before a
quiet joint session of
congress and he asked
that The United States
of America declared war
against The German Empire.
[ Background voice ]
So, off I was into The
United States Army.
I was drafted in
December 1917, my name?
Private first-class Irving
Greenwald E Company the 308.
We are part of the
77th Division.
I was drafted before million
other young brave boys.
Our war was called "The
War to End All Wars".
Just imagine that a
"War to End All Wars" --
it was called the Great War.
[ Trumpet ]
My camp [inaudible] Long Island.
My day started waking up
at 5:30 a.m., for revelry,
drilling with the bayonet
and then, had to put on
and take off a gas mask,
lectures, I will not engage
in any [inaudible],
exercises and supper.
Supper was usually
frankfurters, sauerkraut,
bread, potatoes and coffee.
Lots and lots of coffee.
Not too bad not too good
either, but not too bad.
After supper, I head to the
YMCA to buy some tobacco
or have some ice cream
or to telephone Leah
if I could get a line.
After supper, I head back to
my bunk to do some reading
or some writing, usually
a letter to Leah or momma,
and I always kiss Leah's
picture before I went to bed,
not before saying my
prayers of course.
Can I be honest?
I lay awake many nights
thinking how unfair
and unkind the army was
it since it sends so many
of us boys away from home.
It's not really fair when
you were to think about it.
My favorite days at camp
were always when the passes
to go home for the weekend
were posted up in the wall.
I'd be so happy that I had
to run and I telephone Leah
and she be so delighted that she
would just, she would just cry.
My Leah, she had an angel's
face, she was graceful,
and strong, she was everything,
she was everything to me.
My entire goal on campus was
always to come home to be
with her as much as I could.
When we go home for
the weekends,
I take her to the theater.
The theater would be
full of men in uniform,
we'd always go see Jack O'
Lantern with Fred Stone,
he was without a doubt
my favorite comedian.
I'd always kiss her
outside the theater;
you see it's not very polite
to kiss outside in public.
I'd hold her in my arms
and I'd whisper to God
"can you keep me home and
grant me a year peace,
happiness and a healthy baby".
You see, we were
going to have a child;
we were going to be a family.
I pray to God that he grant me
this one wish, this one wish
that I can hold my child
before I am shipped off.
But I wasn't, I was shipped off
before I ever saw my beautiful
baby Cecily [phonetic] born.
I'd write in my journal
to keep my mind
from picturing the horrors
of my perspective journey.
When the dreaded day came, and
I had to tell Leah that I was,
that I was shipping off,
she was broken hearted.
We both were, we both realized
this might be the last time we
would hear each other's voices.
I pray that I would come
back to her but I fear
that I may never see her again.
So, we were given three
sandwiches, a cup of coffee,
a hundred rounds of ammunition
-- and off to France, we go!
[ Ship sounds ]
We were packed like sardines
on this transport ships,
these were one of the most
comfortable just whatsoever.
No arrangements for bathing
was made, and the toilet
to be overflowing with human
waste, I mean they'll be
so filthy you would deny
yourself from ever using them.
It's a lot of boys on this ship.
So, you get the idea
it's pretty nasty stuff.
I mean we don't catch [grunts]
from the filth and disease
and the food, the food
wasn't much better either.
For breakfast you'd get a
piece of unappetizing fish
and for dinner a piece of meat
that was tough as leather.
It would all be rejected
by everyone.
I mean the only edible
thing would be the pudding
if you could keep it down
I mean, with a foul stench
down below and the tossing
of ship above it was tough
to keep anything down.
I'd eat a few biscuits but
they'd always come back up.
I walked to my bucket like
it was a natural thing.
It's hard to believe but I
find myself missing the food
from camp Upton.
Up until now, I had
not realized the truth
for the geography of the world.
It is 2/3 water, it is
water, water, and water.
I'd come though the rails and
I always dream of home, mamma,
Leah, my soon to
be baby, dolphins,
dolphins would follow our
ship for miles and always jump
and play in the waves,
they all attract many
of us boys to the rails.
We'd all talk and, and
think about the death
that lay ahead for us.
Interesting days, days full
of spirit, full of adventure,
this was our great adventure.
[ Rail sounds ]
On land, we traveled third-class
railway cars, we go from England
and all the way to France and
on the way we see children
and women, oh the
women, the English women,
they had these red cheeks and
red noses, the boy would just go
"wow" when they would
see them, they'd all wave
from their backyards when we
road passed on the trains.
And the food, the
food wasn't so bad.
In France we get for breakfast,
we'd get canned sausage, bread,
butter, jam and coffee,
lots and lots of coffee.
You see, a soldier cannot
fight without coffee.
Once we got to France --
things changed for us.
The first village we came
to was blown to bits,
and then the next, and the next.
Death and destruction grieved
your eyes, you could --
hear, feel the roar from the
battle, [inaudible] lying,
pawns and trains were
shattered and splintered.
The earth, the earth
was filled with holes,
15 feet deep, 25 feet wide.
Monster pits made
by monster guns.
Such a beautiful country wrapped
in so much death
and destruction.
As you got closer to the line
you could feel the earth shiver
-- beneath your feet.
Flashes from the
sky, from the guns
and slow rising a
[inaudible] signals and flares.
It all looked like, like a 4th
of July firework
celebration from back home.
There is an example
of greatness in men,
but it's all being
degraded by the use
to which these machines
are being put to.
[ Explosion ]
Big guns pounding away at the
French towns, turning them
into piles of rubble, you had
to respect the French
people, I did.
Especially the women,
they had so much courage.
They would stood a
tremendous amount of shielding.
I remember one French madame,
a small woman, she was walking
on her bare feet with tears in
her eyes, she had her hands up
and she was saying
"J'ai peur, j'ai peur,
aidez-moi, j'ai peur".
"I'm scared, I'm
scared, please help".
In my opinion, the use of shell
in war is a cowardly
thing to do.
I mean, you're cutting out
combat and it comes at you
so fast, that all you
can do is wait for death.
I'd be glad to fight
face to face.
We were part of a
huge offensive;
it was called The Muse
our Gun Offensive.
Our goal was to drive up between
the Arland [phonetic] forest
and the News [phonetic] river.
You see General Purshins
[phonetic] idea was
to cut the German supply lines
and drive the Germans
out of France.
But the problem with the argon
force was that it was so thick,
with trees, you couldn't see
more than 10 feet in front
of you and it was
filled with frowny bushes
that would slice right through
you when you felt on them.
Up until that offensive,
no one knew if the
American could fight,
but after that offensive,
the world learned how
tough the dull boys were.
Right before our big push,
our brigade general major,
they gathered us
around a French square,
our general looks intently
into each man's eyes --
Boys I know you're dreadfully
keen to get in the game,
and you're all going to punch it
and you'll make America proud --
So, there you have it,
the faith of England
and France in our hands.
I became scare from the first
time since arriving in France.
What scared me the most was the
probability that I would have
to die in a trench on
my, on my wedding day.
I was content that I would
have to die in this war
but I didn't want
to die in a trench
on my wedding anniversary.
I prayed to God that he
would grant me this wish.
I wrote mamma to buy a bouquet
of chrysanthemums for Leah.
I may not be alive on that day
-- but I would want her to know
that I thought of her on
our wedding anniversary.
Over the days I became really
good at writing really small,
and writing letters
to Leah and Momma.
I was really good at
utilizing every inch
of blank space in the letter.
It's a small item to
crawl about but --
paper, paper has a high value in
war, and if you can utilize it
to the fullest you feel
like you've done
something to be proud of.
War has a way of teaching
men how to be proud
of the smallest victories.
Over the next couple of
months, our nights became cold
and became the filthiest most
rats infested places you could
ever imagine.
We lived and fought in
the mud, I hated the mud.
A lot of men died in the mud.
We called our homes
hell on earth.
"Rats", rats would crawl all
over your face when you tried
to sleep, and millions of flies
would feast over the dead men
in the open graves, and
the cooties [phonetic],
the cooties were the
greatest little devils.
I mean, everyone had
them, of all whole sizes
and breeds big [inaudible]
white ones
and they'd always
find a warm spot,
as soon as you put your head
down they crawl down and up
and around your neck
and enter your trousers.
I mean to refrain
from scratching them it would
require all the will power you
can muster.
Over time I, I became shaky
for the continual
thunder of the guns --
It affected -- it
affected your nerves --
It affected a lot of the men --
When a shell would break, I
would hug the ground listening
for fragments of the
hot [inaudible] of metal
to strike upon the earth.
I was right next to the
coronel whose life was safe,
when a piece of shrapnel
came flying in.
If it wasn't for him
having his hand to his face
and eating a piece of bread,
his head would have been
blown completely off.
Luck, luck had a lot
to do whether you
lived or died in war.
It's what scared you the most,
the luck part, it scared me.
The action started that day
when the lieutenant picked me
as a runner, I -- my job
was to carry messages
to and from commanders.
You see they would
send six men out hoping
that one would get through.
It is the most deadly,
suicidal job you can have,
to run between enemy lines,
dodging machine guns fire,
hoping you weren't running past
a German sniper [gun sounds],
waiting to pick you off.
A lot of brave men died as
runners, brave tired men,
dying as -- as errand boys.
But, you know what?
I was glad.
I was glad because
I never wanted
to kill a man with a bayonet.
The English, they loved the
bayonet, they talked to it
with such charm and animation,
"You must love the bayonet!"
I resented that such a killing
instrument could ever be used
in war.
As a runner --
You zig zag through the forest,
you don't just go from point A
to point B, you hide behind
a tree, [gun fire] you fall
to the ground you use your
senses, you run to another tree,
you look for a landmark, you
wait for a shell to explode,
you run, you fall to the ground,
you run, you hide behind a
bush behind a dead [inaudible],
behind a dead soldier.
You see in war we use
anything and everything
if it means your survival, the
smell, the smell of death is all
around you, dead men black
with decay buried [inaudible]
with body parts sticking
out of the ground it is;
it is the most fearful
thing in the dark.
I hated to leave a man
like that, but you have to.
You have to go on; you
find the courage to go on.
Is like, I run up the hill, I
am at the mercy of the snipers
and the shells vivid flashes
of fire, my ears ring,
my heart stops beating as I --
as I run up the hill I think
of home, mama, Leah,
baby Cecily.
I say a prayer to the lord
to get me through this safely
and suddenly, another
shell explosion.
[ Screams ]
I hug the earth and I flat.
I want to go on, it is worse to
wait for death than to face it.
I curse this shell, surprise
that I am, that I'm still alive.
I get up, I run, I run like
that, not a soul to be seen,
every house torn down piles
in the middle of the streets.
I climb over wreckage,
more men rotting,
and I see one man straight
down in front of ruin church,
and I am, I am glad that
he is not rotting away
in some trench or in the woods.
Luck, not to the celeber
[phonetic] farmhouse
as if I [inaudible],
I deliver my messages
and my important papers and
he scolds me, and questions me
for taking so long,
and he orders me
to immediately return
back to the trenches.
[ Whispers ]
And dejected I, yes sir.
I, I must run through the
death and destruction again,
I must run, past the dead
men I see two more dead men,
so awful sights face
black, eyes gone.
I see another one hunched
over position by his gun,
face is indistinguishable.
Its sickens me to run past the
dead men frightened, I run,
I run [runs sounds] through my
heart bursts, I cannot breathe,
I run down the hill,
out of the woods
and back to our, our trenches.
It no longer, occurs to me,
to [inaudible] in battle,
to some distant 4th
of July celebration.
I am incensed, that so many of
our dead men lie in the streets
of the villages near
us unburied.
I want all of us to go down
and have their bodies all
completely buried but,
no volunteers from
any of the dugouts.
I'm not [inaudible] the job any
more than the other boys do,
but I feel out of
decency the men,
the men must be given
a human burial.
Me, Fern [phonetic] and
Summers, we chose to go,
we want to feel human again.
We see one lad with a big
gaping hole in his chest;
six inches wide, it must
have killed him instantly.
I had seen another one, he is
much more of a pitiful sight,
he was burnt to a cinder.
It hurts to look upon them the
dead men, but I, I spill myself
and I perform what I
consider a human beauty.
As we put the men in the graves,
it almost feels as if it,
is a reward for them --
Mentally I feel, I feel sick.
I'm reminded you to write
a letter to, to Leah,
for the simple satisfaction
that I could do it.
I write, and I tell her how much
I love her, and I pray that her
and our baby Cecily are well.
All night long, I
see the dead men.
Especially the man
who was burnt,
I pondered the mystery
of life and dead.
I just witnessed
the wonder of life
in the helplessness of dead.
Why do men do it?
Why did they kill?
Why do they destroy?
The cost of it, the
futility of it.
Why not end this war?
Spear all the men and women, I
mean this war will never be won
at the battlefield, I have no
courage to live, no will to --
To fight, to go on --
I hold on thinking
of Lea, baby Cecily.
My eyes are bad for
all the tear gas.
My throat is sore, my
lungs are congested --
As I look around I see
a war pitiful sight,
I see some of our boys and
French soldiers who are been
in tear gas, they
are in great pain.
Their eyes are red and
swollen, there coughing
and vomiting in there.
Heavily burns around
the arms and the legs.
You see, you cannot
smell mustard gas;
your nose becomes accustomed
to it from smelling it so much.
It almost has a sweet aroma
to it, like onions or garlic,
once you're expose red spots
begin to show upon your skin,
and eventually you feel the
pain and the swelling in nose
and in your lungs and you
die, no, no, you, you drown,
you drown from all the
mucus in your lungs.
It is a brutal weapon --
If she only knew how foolishly
I risked my life today,
she would most definitely cry.
I think how unfair this
business of war is,
especially to all the
mothers and wives back home.
After dinner, our
captain tells us that,
our [inaudible] will be sent
all over to the German lines,
and that we would go
over the top to mop
up after wards into
no man's land.
We would wait for his whistle,
climb out of these trenches,
tumble out, charge 30 yards
to the [inaudible] tangle man
and zigzag towards our
enemy, hoping to scape there.
I grow angry at this war and the
men who prolong it and decide
of so much destruction.
I wonder if I will ever be
given the chance to see home.
You are given orders to wait,
which gives us time to wonder
and shutter about what the
night has stored for us.
In the dark I, I used my
pack for a, for a pillow.
I sit, I wait, I
pray, and I think --
Are we fit to fight?
No.
At 9:00p.m. --
The door to hell is
open [gun explosion].
I mean, every gun fired
for all it's worth,
it is the most wicked
snap and crack to them.
All of which makes it
necessary to shut when talking,
the skies filled up with
red, white, green flares
over the entire German lines.
It is [inaudible] which
continuing to an instant flash,
million twinkling stars
to show up for one second
and appear another's, but
a second later they are
like beautiful dancing lights.
The lieutenant, he comes
tearing down the trench steeping
over [inaudible], heads and
ankles, and then he shouts,
"I need six more runners,
one for each company now".
No volunteers from
any of the dugouts.
I hide my face and then
I hear Greyri [phonetic]!
He picks me again,
he picks his victims.
I, god I, will never make it
home, he also picks Riley,
Soliman [phonetic] and Thompson,
a small man, a good man,
who is so scared of
all the shouting.
That night we were all
scared, but then he tells us
that is our mission to
find first battalion
and that it is imperative
that we stablish a
communication line.
We will wait for his whistle --
[ Clock and Whistle ]
And then we tumble out,
and we go all over the top
into the dark, thorny
bush into no man's land.
It's sticky and dark, and we
are immediately lost [thunders].
Riley and I shout and suddenly I
don't know where a machinegun is
and opens up [gunshots],
and Thompson is shot
in the head, by a machinegun.
Good bald pallid Thompson I
was, this morning I was joking
with him and now he is no more.
A good man, a father
of two and a man
who should have never
been in the army.
I mourn his lost, the
lieutenant returns and scolds
at us for not keeping up.
I believe I can keep
up better than Riley,
so I work my way forward,
stumbling my head,
almost slicing my arms off
against the wet wire
hidden in the brush.
Stabbing my hands and my
face, we are to the best
of my knowledge deep into no
man's land, at plain sight
from plain Kaiser's snipers, the
paces its fast and I'm panting
and lieutenant he just
questionably he stops getting
yells at us, ¡catch up!
Distressingly we saw a living
trenches narrowing wide,
crashing into a brush
thirsty but we cannot rest,
with all the machinegun there's
all around us, breathless,
senseless with fear, lieutenant
draws out his revolver
with a pale face and he
is a sight for an artist.
We must hurry to the other side
of the hill before we are cut
down by machinegun fire.
The gun sound, the thunder,
the flares are lightning,
and the rain is [explosion
sounds] and then suddenly,
right in from of lieutenant
and Riley a shell explodes,
and I literally watch
them [Explosion] --
Disappear.
>> Mrs. Lea Greenwall,
deeply regret to inform you
that it is officially reported
that private Erwin W. Greenwall
infantry was wounded in action,
October 8th, degree
undetermined,
further information
when received.
Is October 22th.
I've been in the hospital
for about two weeks.
Food hasn't been so bad,
not so good, but not so bad.
For breakfast, I get a
bowl of rice, applesauce,
bread and coffee, lots
and lots and coffee.
I can't get enough to coffee.
Every few days I get cornmeal
mush with plenty of sugar
and what seems to be real milk,
some of the best milk I've
had in a long, long time.
As I clear the windowpanes
to look
out what strikes me is the
change in color in nature,
what used to be green and
is now red, yellow and gold.
But I noticed the most
because I don't --
I don't hear the continual
thunder from the shells anymore.
It is quiet.
The sun screams upon my back
and I can hear a [inaudible]
bell ringing outside.
Every morning I listen
to it, it's such a,
such a pleasant reminder
of home.
Miss Johnson, my nurse, she
comes to clean my wound.
She is a kind, plumped red-faced
girl from the Lemoyne, Iowa.
As she removes my dressing
a stream of pause flows
through my wound, I was
struck by a piece of scrap
from the shell that killed
the lieutenant and Riley.
The doctor, a first
lieutenant, a young man.
He is of the opinion
that there is piece
of shrapnel still
lodging my wound
that it must be fished out.
He says, "Son, I need to
do a little fishing" --
So, he turns me over my side and
says, "This is going to hurt".
For ten minutes, with his
fingers he pokes into the back
of my leg, Miss Johnson
she holds down my leg,
but I can't keep very
still, every time he digs
into the back of my leg.
He touches a nerve
I -- I clench my fists, I grit
my teeth, I breath heavily,
anything to help me
withstand without screaming.
This fishing and poking
goes of everyday I was
in the hospital just
about until finally I say,
"No that was enough of
your fishing and poking".
The doctor gives me a
dirty look, dissatisfied
with my resolve, he orders
Miss Johnson to banish my leg
and that is the end of that.
As I look around, instead
of strong straight men,
I see cripples in
every direction.
They are all beyond cure.
I noticed a boy coming out of
the operation room with one leg,
and he has tears on his
face and he is crying
for the incredible pain.
Seems another doctor performed
one of his delicate operations.
I notice a girl face foil,
17, who later I found
out enlisted when it was 15.
He continually, he
continually cries for his mama.
He's having a piece of
shrapnel removed from his spine,
10 inches of his spine show
from the skull downwards.
I see men with great
burns faces distorted,
all of them with fig
creeping wounds in them --
And deeply affected and sadden
by all the mothers and wives,
who gave up so many great
boys for this cause.
And all the mothers I heard
so many boys cry out to,
dying in the trenches
and in no man's land.
Deep feelings are
long of missing me.
I'm longing for a letter
of from Leah or mama
that I cannot suppress.
I dream of home, of Leah coming
to visit me with my baby.
They are delicious dreams.
I have faith that in a
few days, I will be home,
and I will be able to give
Leah and baby Cecily a kiss.
On October 31st, the
war started to end.
Turkey capitulates and agrees
to lay down all her arms
and Austria, she
throws up her hands.
And on November 4th, a
soldier comes running
in with a newspaper
and he shouts
for our silence, he
has our attention.
There is an expected law
and then calls it, "boys,
Germany has agreed to sign the
armistice with the allies".
Three cheers and a yell that
could be heard all the way back
to Paris [cheers], church
bells ring and the friends
with all the joy with the news.
Shorty, shorty gets on the
piano and he starts swinging
from the [inaudible]
leading the cheering.
I cheered standing
up in bed and Walter,
Walter plays the stars
spangled banner [music],
and all the boys, they
gather around the piano.
There is singing and
shouting, and dancing,
and drinking, plenty
of drinking.
I wasn't a drinking man but
that day I had a few drinks,
and as I look out the window,
I remember thinking how glad
that I was alive and that this
war, this war is finally over.
[ Music ]
A week later, Monday, November
11th, 1918, the armistice
with Germany is signed, all
terms are agreed upon it,
all fires ceases at 11 o'clock.
And my first thoughts are for
the lads, no doubt many who gave
up their life's right
before 11 o'clock.
It is a pity.
On our transport ships we,
we steam into the
harbor of Newport News.
Landlines, twinkling like mirror
stars and I can see the flashes
from Tralee wires, all evidence
that we are in good old America.
I don't think of America
as much as I think
of Leah and baby Cecily.
On our ships I get my things,
I make my bed, I tight my bunk,
I dress, I shine my shoes,
I shave with infinite care.
At 9:30 I'm given my pass,
I am ready to go
[inaudible], I walk on air.
The doctor, he comes
on board and he --
Checks my wound,
no pus, no pain.
I make it down to the
doctor without assistance
and I see the ever-present
Red Cross ladies
with chocolate and cigarettes.
I will never forget the
bravery and kindness
of the women of the Red Cross.
I see advertising signs, and
wooden houses and civilians,
all of which are a
sight so familiar to me
and glad it's my heart, I sing
and I whistle all the way home.
When we get to camp Stewart,
I am reminded of what I said
when I left camp Upton
that I hope I never
see the bears again,
but how glad I am
to see them now.
I am home --
I know it; I can feel
it in every thought
in every bone in my body.
I cannot believe
my good fortune.
I am finally going home.
[ Music and applauses ]
>> Hi everyone my name is
Megan Harris I'm the reference
specialist for the Veterans
History Project, and I wanted
to say thank you for coming
to this wonderful performance.
I hope that it resonated
with you.
In the audience, we
actually have members
of Irving Greenwald's family.
His daughter and grandchildren.
And I wanted to say
thank you to them
for donating this
wonderful diary,
Irving Greenwald original diary
on which his performance
was based.
So, that it could be shared and
interpreted in this performance.
So, we have a few
minutes I'd love
to answer questions I
know Mr. Taurel would
like to answer questions
from you as well.
And I'd also like to
encourage you to go
up to the World War I exhibit,
to see Irving Greenwald
original diary
on which the performance
was based.
So, I know that mister Taurel
has another performance
at 2:00 p.m. Actually, a
different production and he said
that he would be able to
spend just a few minutes
with us answering questions
about the performance
and his process, if
anyone has any questions?
Yes.
[ Inaudible question ]
Yes, well my 2 o'clock
performance is called The
American Soldier and it is
based on different letters
and different veterans
from all the wars.
So, The Library of
Congress contacted me
and offered me six diaries
to kind of look through them
and they asked me if I would be
interested in creating a project
to honor, to celebrate
the centennial
of the first World War,
and at first I was very,
as I've said it many times,
in couple interviews --
the work that someone did
is so valuable because a lot
of the diaries, all
the other diaries,
they weren't transcribed
so they were written.
So, by her tight writing it
and then being digitized it
allowed me to basically treat it
as a text and I can basically
read it and take notes from it.
And so, from that process I just
basically created to the stuff
that I really like and try to
creating a begin, middle and end
with my director, Patrick Lewis,
he should be here
somewhere, their he is.
And so, that's how, that's
how we kind of, we came to it.
But I mean, it was a very
tedious long process still,
it took me six months, the goal
was always to, do I need it now?
[Laughter].
I didn't need it
there, I hate mics.
So, yes, I basically what I
would do is I would highlight
stuff that I like and I
would put it into a document
and then I would read through
that, and I read the diaries
from beginning to end.
So, and then eventually I go
from 30.000 words, 15.000 words,
10.000 words, and I finally had
needed to get it to 7.000 words.
And then I started crafting
it into what it is today.
But the diary is so powerful,
he was such an eloquent writing,
I mean, you could make four
plays out of his diary.
So, it was really tough, because
if anybody knows anything
about editing or writing,
deletion is the toughest thing
to do, because I did his passage
on the ship was about as crucial
as his time on the
trenches and he really talks
about it really elaborately,
but you know,
in fairness to theatrical
production we had
to move past that so, yes.
>> What do you regret
the most leaving out?
If you had another 30
minutes, what would you put in?
>> Douglas Taurel:
That's a great question.
The very beginning
because there was a couple,
two moments that I couldn't find
a way, because I was restrained
by time, she said "you have
45 to 50 minutes only",
so that was a big parameter
for what I had to do.
But there was a moment in
the diary in the beginning
where he really doesn't
want to go off to war,
and he actually gets on a train
and he is going to go AWOL,
and he was a man apparently,
for what I deduced,
his name was everything
to him --
and so he was terrified that
Leah, he loved his wife so much,
that Leah would be stained
with having a name of a husband
who would had gone AWOL.
So, he literally
gets on the train
and he jumps off last minute,
and he talks about it, and how,
the steam the engine,
is something right
out of Harry Potter the
way he describes it.
And it's beautiful, and I had
it in there, but it didn't,
it just, it didn't fit with the
act that I was trying to do,
what we were trying to do.
And so, the other point,
when he's in the trenches,
he is actually told he can
go home, and he is static
and then they come
up to him and say,
"I'm sorry we made a mistake, it
is not you it is someone else".
And so, he is just like
that's where that line comes
"I have no will to live, I have
no courage to fight anymore".
So, I took that line
and I put it there
because he is really
devastated from that,
and that's when he says,
"I think I will never
make it home now".
And he was part the
last battalion,
if anybody knows anything
about the last battalion is,
they suffered tremendous
casualties, and from what I get
from Greeny, that's
how I call him
because that's how the boys
call him they call him Greeny.
He was a fairly successful
man, and he had a good shop,
you know, he had a
wife who had a bay,
he had a good life he sound
like he was very educated,
he would have to be
to write like this.
And so, to see him part of
the trenches, living with rats
and there were parts were
they were starving to death,
they had no water
they had a choice
to drinking chlorinated
water or no water.
To see him go from that extreme
to that extreme, and then,
and the whole time all he
does is to talk about Lea
and baby Cecily, so he
must have been madly,
would they be madly in love?
I had to ask because --
[ Background voice ]
Because it feels like, I mean,
almost every paragraph
he mentions her name,
so those are the two big spots
that I wish I could have
somehow crafted, you know.
It seemed like he wants to go
home so bad that he even gets
into a train he's willing to
go AWOL, but he gets scared
because he's afraid of what
that will do to his name
and he jumps the train, so yes.
Ask her.
>> Who were the other
five people
of the other five diaries?
>> Douglas Taurel: Those were
his, that's my son [laughter]
of course my son is
going to ask a question.
Those were his buddies, he, they
found a lot of buddies, son.
>> You can see some of
them in the exhibition
if you go upstairs [inaudible].
Your question.
>> Your performance is so
rich, I hope it is being
and the editorial job I didn't
realize you had also created the
text from the diary
it's a splendid thing.
I hope this is going
to be recorded and,
that you're recording
it somewhere,
so it can be broadcast
to a larger.
>> Douglas Taurel:
Thank you, they are.
Broadcast I don't know but
they're definitely recording it.
>> OK, and the other question I
have, I understand he had a son
who died in World War II, can we
hear something about his life?
>> Douglas Taurel: I
don't know much about,
I just found out trough Naomi.
You had a brother that died in
the Second World War, correct?
>> Yes, I mean, the performance
is really about the diary
and it's the story of
the diary, so, you know.
>> Generally with veteran's
projects, history projects,
we let the material speak
for itself and essentially
with is archive it's designed
to do is to make it accessible
for researchers, for performers,
for the general public to read
into it and, read into
it what they will.
So, we don't do a lot of
research into the backstory
of materials, simply because
that's the job for researchers
and for other folks who are
going to use the materials.
>> There's one last
question over here?
>> Just, the journal did
it end when you got back
or did he continue to write
and was there more beyond
and how his life
developed after that?
>> Douglas Taurel:
It pretty much ends,
it pretty much ends the
way I ended it in the play.
It's actually so well written
and when you're reading it,
the problem even with Greeny's
diary and my second show --
I've dealt with that a lot.
Soldiers, for the most time
they write in fragments,
a lot of them, because
they're just trying to get
through the day, and
Greeny did the same thing.
He wrote huge chunks where
is just tedious boring stuff
and fragments, fragments, and
then he would just explode
into this amazing
eloquent prose.
But when you're reading his
diary, I mean, it ends like,
it goes into two sections
as you're reading it,
he's literally running through
the trenches and then Riley dies
and the this dies, and
explosion, explosion, explosion
and then literally it says,
"end of entry", like what?
What do you mean end of entry?
And you're flicking through it.
There's got to be another entry,
and next entry starts off with
"It's October 22nd I've been
in the hospital for two weeks".
So, that he was injured
in September 28th,
so you so he's probably
injured fairly bad
and he probably was unconscious
is what I imagined, and so then,
then it goes into the
hospital, hospital goes
on for a long time, they
actually move them to hospitals.
But then he comes
home and that's,
and that's basically
how it ends.
It actually ends with
him making a phone call
in the snow calling
Leah: "is today I'm going
to go make a phone call,
it's pretty cold out there
but I'm going to go
ahead and brave it,
I want to hear her voice"
and that's the end of diary
so it's very cinematic.
Chris.
>> I think we have time
for one quick question.
>> Were there any stories
that really surprised you
that you didn't expect when you
were initially going into it?
>> Douglas Taurel: Yes, no and
yes, I mean I talked about this
with my director, but it really
is and I've become a student
of War because of my,
my next show, my, my,
the other show that
I've written.
So, I've been studying
all the battles a lot,
and all these brave men and
women have, their commitment
and sacrifice is something that
we can never really measure
but when you study
the first World War,
it really is like a horror show.
I mean because it's
yes, but you have
to remember it it's
the beginning
of the Industrial Age is the
beginning of the machinery.
It was the first time that we
are using machines to fight
in war and so, society and human
beings really had not been,
there's actually moments
in the first World War
where the French were still
trying to fight on Calvary,
and they kept getting
gunned down by machine guns
and they couldn't understand why
their tactics won't be in work
and this went on, on both sides.
So, they lost, compared
to what Americans lost
to what the French and English
lost, is a drop in a bucket,
they lost like 17 million men.
I mean, it's on, today anybody
did that it would be a revolt.
So, I think what's surprising
it's just the pure carnage
of what the war is and the
way Greeny describes it,
it describes it like dead
men black and decay faces so,
when you're reading you just
like it's hard to believe so.
I'll just leave it at that
not to go too deep into it,
the gore stuff, but it just
how, how violent that war was.
>> Again, thank you
so much for coming
and we encourage you again to
go to the exhibit ant perhaps
to come back at 2:00 p.m.
>> Douglas Taurel: 2:00 p.m.
>> For a different performance
but equally moving, I'm sure.
So, thank you.
[ Applauses ]
>> Karen Lloyd: Good
afternoon and welcome
to the most beautiful
building in Washington DC
and to The Coolidge Auditorium.
I'm Karen Lloyd and as director
of The Veterans History Project
and as a retired army aviator,
I'm also the Widow sibling
and child of veterans,
I am so pleased
to welcome you especially
the veterans,
to The Library of Congress.
The library makes a special
effort this week in particular
to honor and recognize
veterans and their families,
and to explore the
ways that military men
and women have connected
to home and family during
and after their service
from World War I
through the current conflicts.
We are proud to collaborate
with our colleagues
from across the library to
offer a series of events titled
"Coming Home Veterans Day
at the Library of Congress".
In the back you will find
this handy card with all
of today's programs many of
which align with our exhibit
"Echoes of the Great War".
This exhibit examines
the upheaval of World War
as Americans confronted it,
both at home and abroad.
Located here in the Jefferson
building it is compelling
with compellingly rendered
and offers glimpses
of The Human Condition
Transcendent From Time
and Place, in part
through over 30 collections
from the veterans
history project.
I hope you'll find
time to see it.
I also ask that you
consider taking a copy --
Of the of the libraries
magazine which in part focuses
on the Veteran History
Project and our collections.
Now a word about the
Veterans History Project:
it provides inspiration
and instruction
to foster a nationwide volunteer
effort for individuals to reach
out to the veterans and their
lives and listen really listen,
and then donate those oral
histories and personal narrative
of their veterans from World War
I through the current conflicts.
Veterans like Mr. Greenwald
whose family graciously donated
his interview VHP and whose
words came alive this morning
through the portrayal
by Douglas Taurel.
If you are inspired by
these veterans' stories,
consider the veterans
history project
for your veterans' story,
and thank you again
for joining us today.
[ Music ]
>> Douglas Taurel: I learned
three powerful lessons
when I joined the military.
The first lesson I
learned was discipline,
you will do as you're told.
When you get off that bus
on recruitment day you know
you're not in Kansas anymore.
[Whistle sounds] Come on, let's
go, let's go, get on the line!
Do you hear me?
Look straight you maggot!
Every one of you will
answer me with aye aye sir!
Am I understood?
Aye aye sir!
Get your hand up in the air!
I said, get your hands down!
Aye aye sir!
I said get your hands
up in the air!
Aye aye sir!
I said get your hands down!
Turn to the right!
Aye aye sir!
Look at me now!
You will move as
fast and as intensely
as you can, am I understood?
Aye aye sir!
You will do what we
say, when we say it
and how we say it,
am I understood?
Aye aye sir!
[ Music ]
I remember the stand the
country over the [inaudible]
and all the destruction
of [inaudible].
I was only 13 or 14 years
old then, and just beginning
to understand what was
going on in the country.
My grandfather, he
taught very little to me
about the French
and Indian wars.
We lived in a small
fond back in Boston,
little red house surrounded
by birch people trees.
When I would ask him what
it was like to fight in war,
he would answer me with the
steely blue eyes of his,
almost as if the eyes
itself were speaking to me,
he would say "son war is
hard, you march, you march,
and you march some more,
don't ever forget that".
"But that's great grandfather
that's what I want to do,
I want to fight,
I want to march,
I want to experience
the excitement of life,
I want to be a patriot".
My grandfather he worked
daily in the fields,
he developed the taste of
agriculture from his days
in battle, he loved having
his hands in the earth.
I sometimes catch him,
working in the field smiling
as he finally achieved
something,
he'd get up at 4:00 a.m., and
he wouldn't come in to sundown
and then he'd just sit by
the fire, he'd just stare.
He seemed to prefer the silence,
my mother told me he had led
the great invasion of the canon
and he had fought many,
many great battles.
One day after dinner I kneel
down by him and I asked him,
I said "grandfather
please, tell me what it's
like to really fight in
war, to experience battle",
he turned to me with
his blue eyes of his
and he said "truly splintered.
They become projectiles, jagged
shards of wood going into faces
and eyes, the forest it screams,
officers and soldiers roar,
horses shriek, guns are
blasting everywhere,
and the ground is covered with
the dead and the air resounds
with the groans of the dying".
Well I ignored my grandfather's
advice, and I went ahead,
enlisted, and engaged
myself for the preservations
for the liberties of America.
For I thought that now was
the time for us Americans
to free ourselves from
the English and set
up a government of our own.
On this cold morning, I find
myself far away from home,
away from my farm and my
grandfather was right,
war is hard, very, very hard.
We are here in Valley Forge
in freezing temperatures,
nearly starved, we have
not eaten in four days
and as many nights except the
piece of [inaudible] a stick
of wood, if that
can be called food.
I miss my farm, and I
specially miss my grandfather.
And I long for the day to be
back in that farm in Boston,
for I believe I too,
have developed a taste
of agriculture pursuits.
[ Music ]
Dear Bill, I've come to
this wall again to see
and touch your name,
and as I do,
I wonder if anybody here
realizes next to your name,
in this black wall, is
your mother's heart.
A heartbroken fifteen years ago
when you lost your
life in Vietnam.
As I look at you name
William R. Stocks.
I think of the times I must
have wondered how scared
and homesick you must have been
in that strange country
called Vietnam,
and how it must have
changed you.
For you were always such
a happy good-looking kid,
never sad and never unhappy.
Until the day I die, I'll always
you how you laughed at me,
even when I was really
angered before I knew we'd be
laughing together.
This past New Year's Day
I finally got my answer.
I talked on the phone
to a friend
of yours from Michigan, Jim.
Jim told me had spent
your last Christmas
and the last four months
of your life with you.
Jim told me he was
there when you died.
He saw how the helicopter
crashed.
How you were scheduled to fly
and how your pilot
had been replaced
by a less experienced
pilot and the cause
of the crash was unknown,
how were you hit by an enemy,
or hit an enemy far or you
hit a pole or something.
He also told me how you men
were like sitting ducks,
they would send you men out in
the open to draw the enemy out
and then they send in the planes
in the big guns that take over
but in the meantime --
Death came to so many of you.
He also told me instead of a
yellow streak a lot of them
and got a mean streak.
You need to stay that streak
got bigger and meaner,
everyone except you how you stay
the same happy gold lucky kid
you are when you got to Vietnam.
And how you warmed the
friendliness to everyone to you,
and how your lieutenant
nicknamed you Spanky.
and soon your entire group's
nickname is Spanky's gang.
He also told me how, how hard
your death was for everyone.
How you of all people should not
have been the one to have died.
How you were their --
How you were their
moral support.
I know when I got off the phone
with Jim he must have
relived that all over again.
I told him how much I love
them, and I thanked them
for being your friend.
How lucky you were to
have him as a friend
and him to have had you.
It hurts to write these
letters and to leave them here
at this wall, but I must face
this pain and put it to rest.
I'm OK son,
I'll see you next June.
[ Music ]
[ Drums sounds ]
My second lesson was teamwork.
We were doing exercise by the
ripple, which means there's
about 34 to 36 of us with our
company command in the middle,
and they're called by the
ripple because they go one
after another, sort of
like a, like dominoes.
And if anyone makes a mistake
in the exact way how you're
told how to do these exercises,
you have to start all
over the beginning.
And Adam Smith a southern back
Missouri kid, a really nice guy
but he wasn't a good soldier,
he made a mistake and we had
to start all over the beginning.
So, my company commander
comes up and he starts yelling
"Is anybody here
angry at recruit Smith
for making a mistake?"
So, I speak up "yes sir, I am
angry at recruit Smith sir,
I fell we all shouldn't
start at the beginning
because of recruit Smith sir!"
Well that was a life longing
lesson because I, and only I had
to do all the exercises.
I had to go to each recruit,
state my name, do the exercises
and then ask them if I
had done them correctly.
"My name is recruit Williams
and I will be doing
exercises for you".
[ Background sounds ]
"Did I do my exercises
correctly?
My name is recruit Williams
and I will be doing
exercises for you".
[ Background sounds ]
"Did I do my exercises
correctly?
My name is recruit Williams
and I will be doing
exercises for you".
[ Background sounds ]
"Did I do my exercises
correctly?"
Needless to say, it was
humbling to say the least.
So, my company commander
comes up and starts yelling
"are you still angry at recruit
Smith for making a mistake?"
--
And at that minute a
light bulb went off,
I just realized what this was,
this was a game, life is a game,
you have to play
the game with rules,
we're all in this together, and
no man is above another man,
and the way you survive is
by helping your fellow man
and working together as a team.
Is the way you survive war and
it's the way you survive life.
[ Music ]
I'm tired of being scared.
I just want to come home and
no matter how hard I try,
I can't seem to come home.
When it goes off to war,
you just don't come back
the same person you were
as you left, you just don't
sit at the dinner table
and say [inaudible] now.
It just doesn't work that way.
The adjustment is
tough, it's real tough.
I have an incredible temper
now, one I never had before.
I'm abusive to my
wife, can't hold a job,
nothing matters to me anymore.
And the worst part of being
back home is I don't want
to touch my son, I'm terrified
of infecting him with the evil
that I've seen and done.
To grab my boy with the
same bloody hands, I feel,
as I would destroy his
purity, I would infect him.
When you go off to war
you goes off as a kid,
but when you come back is all,
is dirty inside, is all-hollow.
I was in the first
lining face at Inujima.
I, I saw hundreds of dead men,
faces gone, bodies exposed,
that's what Inujima was,
it was a killing field.
I mean, when we landed
and we took a hell
of a [inaudible] they
met us with everything.
I remember just running on
the beach and cover my head
and crying like a baby
when my knees were shaking,
my body was trembling
like it was,
like it was, like it was jelly.
When we were on the beach, my
captain comes up and he yells,
"I need three guys to go with me
to see what the jets are up to!"
I thought anything is better
than being stuck here.
So, me, Vincent and Lucky we
volunteered, we walked over,
over the rocks into
the dark jungle.
It was silent.
It was as if you walk through
the front door or something told
who didn't want you to be there.
After several hours,
we realize we was lost.
"Hey man, where the
fuck are we?"
At that moment my captain
was shot, and I spot the jap
who shot him, so I bring my
rifle and I bring him down,
and Lucky yells "make
sure he's dead, do it!".
So, I run up to him and
I see him still moving
so I bring up my knife and --
[ Whispers and screams ]
I just slit a man's throat.
No matter what the
army train me to do
but they can never
train me to what it's
like to kill another human
being, and I, and I just did,
and I felt terrible
because of it.
I walked away, I looked at
my hand, and it was covered
in blood, as if someone
spilled a red gallon
of red paint all over me.
When it goes off to war
you don't kill someone
in the kind way, you
do it with cruelty.
You're scared, you kill and if
you don't kill you get killed.
War is nasty, is terrible.
There are few things
you did or endured
in combat ever leave you,
the thought of this events
there is vivid in my mind
as I was, as I was in combat.
Physical wounds generally
heal in time.
But the memories of battle
they, they cut to deep they
They burn your soul, they
never go away, no, never.
I was a nice kid before I left,
and now I'm not, I'm broken.
I've become good friends with
Jim and Jack you may know
as Jim Beam and Jack Daniels.
They help me forget.
[ Helicopter ]
Greeny, you are working too
hard man, what are you doing?
Search and destroy,
digging holes.
Greeny it ain't matter what you
do man the [inaudible] could be
right in front of you and
you still wouldn't know it.
They're so better on these hills
doesn't matter how many holes
you dig or [inaudible]
bombs you drop on them,
we ain't never going
to get them out.
So, stop digging that
hole man and come
over here and smoke some shit.
You got to take it easy now man,
or else you ain't
going to make it.
Ain't no cowards at this
place, just the life
or dead, here, smoke some.
You don't smoke?
[ Laughter ]
You will, give yourself a
week and you'll be smoking,
you got to smoke to
escape the beast,
escape hell, escape reality.
Doesn't matter how much
training you've done,
Vietnam is a whole new
fucked up world man,
this place is a steam bag, 24/7
infested with bugs and insects
and snakes, and I
hate snakes man.
They got the most
poisonous snake
in the world here the two step.
And you know why it's
called the two-step.
Because if that son
of a bitch bites you,
you get two steps
before you die.
[ Laughter ]
Oh shit! Green, there's a
two-step right next to you,
no I ain't messing
around is right there.
I'm just going to
reach over there
and get my knife,
don't move man.
I'm just messing around, I'm
just messing with you baby,
take it easy man
here man smoke some.
Aww damn, you reading?
Now, where are you from?
Iowa? Man, you are
far from home,
this place ain't
nothing like Iowa man.
Tell me something man,
what's everyone saying
about us back home?
Because I keep reading in my
dad's letter that he's starting
to have doubts about
us and this war,
says we shouldn't be over here.
There's people back home
marching and protesting
against us calling
us baby killers.
I ain't a baby killer
man, these sons of bitches
up in the hills ain't no babies,
if they are they're some badass
motherfucking babies firing 8mm
machine guns at us.
Yes, if everyone from
back home were with us
when we were stranded and
surrounded by four battalions
of NDAs they'd thought
different about us in this war.
Pinned own taking fire
from every direction.
Chasing around flying
through the air,
buddies being blown away.
See, that's the shit
about war Greeny,
that no one prepares you
for, it's the sound of war,
bullets cracking, bombs landing,
[inaudible] of shells exploding,
men screaming and
yelling for their mommas.
It's just a big ball of deity
noise man and when you hear
that shit, that's when you
know the beast is hungry man
and that's why you smoke
man, to escape the beast!
Every time I get high
man I get closer to home,
and see myself walking
through the back door
and hear my mama go "dinner's
almost ready baby" sit
on the back porsche and watching
these Texas sunsets it'll
be quiet.
When I get out of
here I don't want
to hear another thing
about Vietnam or war.
What's that?
You want a hit?
Yes, I thought you'd
come around.
[ Music ]
I've been back from Iraq
for about a year now
and I already want to go back.
I miss the edge baby, yes.
I miss that, I miss the feeling
of 50-caliber machine gun,
the feeling of the power
coursing through your veins
with the pull of a trigger,
the sounds of locking
and loading your guns,
[shoots] get some!
Man, I miss that.
But what I miss the most, I
miss my buddies, my brothers.
But it's crazy because I know
that once I go back
I'd be all depressed.
I wish I could feel more
comfortable being back home,
my wife she doesn't, she
doesn't want me to come back,
and I don't blame her.
But I've only done
one deployment,
some of my buddies have
done two, three, four,
five deployments they've been
back to back to back to back!
Some of their crappie
experiences are
so freaking overwhelming.
So, I've been back home,
I've been reminded how
much I miss my wife.
I do, I love her.
When you're over there you
miss the feel of a women,
you miss the smell of
a women, but I'm having
such a hard time finding
things to talking her about,
I mean it's not her fault it's
just a lot of things she says
to me it's so meaningless and
senseless "honey should we go
to Kids Sauce for dinner or
should we go to the movies?
But I think what we really
need to do is paint the kitchen
and get some brand new frapes,
what we really need is
a brand-new crock pot".
What do I care about a crockpot?
I mean I don't tell her that
but that's what I'm thinking,
how can I talk about this
mundane crap when I've been
over there blowing crap away
like a freaking videogame.
Everyone back here they don't
have to sing appreciation
for being alive as you do
because it ain't life or death,
everyone here [inaudible]
they can't seem to relate you
because it ain't life and death.
I mean, as a sense of purpose
[inaudible] the only gain
in town.
Only thing that make life
worth living back home,
they're not [inaudible]
combat, I mean we talk
about fire fights, we
dream about fire fights!
I don't think I'll
ever be satisfied
with a normal life
whatever that is,
I think I'm ruined
for everything else.
War, war is a lot of things but
let me tell you, it is useless
to pretend exciting
isn't one of them,
it is fucking insanely
exciting, the sounds it makes,
the machinery of it, the urgency
of it's use, the consequences
of almost everything about it's
the most exciting things anyone
engaged in war has
ever experienced.
We've talked about this
stuff with our friends
with our families, they'll
never know, they'll never know.
War is bad, but let me tell you,
holding a 50-caliber
machine gun is amazing!
War is life multiplied by some
number you've never even heard
of, 20 minutes of
combat is more life
than you can scrape
together in a lifetime
of doing something else.
I know it's sad but being
back home is boring!
There's an aliveness when you're
in combat, everything is living,
like this intense quiet, all
you hear is your footsteps,
I'd be firing my saw
[ Shoots ]
OH men, this is it baby!
This is combat!
Everything is living!
You're never more alive
until you're almost dead.
War is hell but it's
also mysterious
and beautiful for
all its horror.
War makes you a man
but it's crazy
because I know once I go
back I'll be all depressed
and then I come back here and
all I can think about is war.
Is like I have, like
a I have a mistress.
I've got my wife which is love
and this hot sexy dangerous
mistress which is war baby!
[ Screams ]
[ Screams and Music ]
He's going to come
back, how do I know?
I just know.
Can I promise?
Of course, I can promise, your
daddy loves you very much.
I miss him a lot and my
son really misses them,
we have to give up so
much for him to go back --
This is going to be his
third tour in Afghanistan.
When dinner rolls around and I
start thinking about what I have
to make for dinner, I forget
that Mike is leaving us today
and then afterwards
we're going have to sit
at the dinner table alone.
The first night is
always the hardest.
You have this little one who
is moving all your emotions
and you're trying to act
like everything is OK
even though you don't feel
like it's OK.
He misses a lot of
events in our life,
events that we can't get back,
so we think of creative ways
to keep him with us, and one of
the ways was Mike on a stick,
we're taking this picture that
you put on a Popsicle stick.
I know it's weird, it's
definitely when will we go
to a restaurant, so we ask Mike
if my son can have
chicken tenders.
The waiters always looked
at us like we belong
in in a psych ward or something
but, it helps it really helps.
I miss him a lot, but my son,
my son really has a hard time.
I miss my daddy so much,
he misses all my events
in my life like, like
when I became a week low,
a lot of my friends who don't
know about the military just
from what they see
in movies and stuff
like that they think
it's kind of cool
that my dad wears a uniform and
fires guns and stuff like that.
But it's really hard to say bye
to daddy, I miss him so much.
Hey don't tell anybody, OK?
Because I don't know if
this is legal but I'm trying
to invent a machine that
can hook my daddy up to
so that he never
goes away again.
[ Music ]
This is my son Jeff, he was a
real of the real fun-loving boy,
a real social boy,
clown real rascal.
"Jeff, would you please
stop jumping off the couch?
Yes, I know you can fly like
Superman, but I don't want you
to do it in the living room".
You really enjoyed life.
I'm often asked if I
had the opportunity
to trade the mental wound that
he suffer in Iraq for the bullet
that he didn't receive,
would I trade it?
I don't know.
I just hated to see him
suffer the way you did.
I remember when he came
back I really thought
that that was a new chapter,
that was a new beginning for him
but soon, after he came back,
I realize that he was
far from unscathed.
That the wounds he didn't
understand, was starting
to terrify him and the rest of
us, his, his body had returned
but that wasn't our boy anymore.
He had become someone we've
never even seen before.
It was on the first
anniversary of the Iraq War.
He and his girlfriend were
supposed to go to Vermont
to celebrate and for some reason
they had a tremendous fight
and he became really
depressed and he came back home
and he stayed with us.
And he was sitting in the
living room staring at the fire
in the fireplace, I'd
go up to him and say,
"son let's go let's go to
the VA and get some help"
and he always reply with
"I can't go Dad, I'm sorry,
I just can't go, nothing matters
to me anymore I'm sorry, sorry".
He was so terrified of the
stigma he didn't want his unit
to see him as weak, that night
he came to me he asked me if,
if you can sit in my lap and if
we can rock together like we did
when he was a little boy.
I felt lost and I felt
confused, but I said,
"of course you can son,
of course you can".
So, here I had this
marine, sitting in my lap
and I told him how much I
loved him and how much I,
how proud I was of him
and I begin to rock him,
and it felt natural
holding my little boy again.
I thought he was coming
back to us that night.
We both went to bed
and I slept peacefully
for the first time
in a long time.
You know, when your little ones
grow up, they never really grow
up I mean you worry about
them the same way you did
when they were first born.
The next morning I went to
his room to knock on the door
and the door was locked,
"hey Jeff open up son,
Jeff open the door" that would
be the last time I would hold
my son.
Would I ask if he would
have a, a quicker death?
I would have just asked
him to have a good life.
I remember at the funeral
cursing God "why did you give it
to us if you were going to
let him suffer so much?"
I wish I could put my
arms around him and say,
"Son let's go, get some
help, not only for you
but for the both of us".
So, now what's happened is
we become his, his voice,
and we don't do it in anger and
what happens a lot of families
and come up to us and said
we don't want to be like you,
we don't want to be grieving
parents so we tell them
about the mistakes we made
and tell him how hard it is
how hard it's going to be
and there's going to be days
when you feel you can't
do anything right, but,
but don't give up don't
ever, ever, ever, give up.
And don't think for a
second they won't do it.
My greatest sin as a
father was thinking
that Jeff wouldn't commit
suicide, not my boy.
[ Music ]
Shit, this is hard.
There's a lot of things you take
for granted in life, you know?
You don't know how valuable
something is until you lose it.
When I lost my arm I
really wanted to die,
I didn't know what my with
my wife would think of me,
what my son would think of me.
I felt like I let my
family down, you know?
I couldn't be the
man I used to be.
I sometimes I'll be
looking at my son wondering
if he's thinking, "I don't
like the way my dad looks now".
The hardest thing about losing
a limb is how you see yourself
in the mirror, you have this
image that you're trying to see
but when you look in there
he's not there anymore he's,
he's, he's gone.
One of the things that
I found really hard was,
when I came back I really
thought it was going to be
like a, you know,
a nice sunny day,
the marine corps band was going
to be playing, it was going
to be confetti and
silly strings.
When I came back there was
nothing, nothing at all.
And I didn't think it would
affect me, but it did, you know?
It bothered me a lot.
I used to be a pitcher in
college and I was good.
It didn't matter if
it was a strikeout
or a homerun I can focus on
the next pitch, you know?
And that mental force
could serve me well
on the battlefield.
I mean, I found dozens of
IDs and I saved my brothers.
But when I came back I
couldn't focus on anything, no.
I keep getting these pains in my
left side, and I keep imagining
in my arm is still there but
only like three inches long,
which is freaking weird, because
not only did I lose my arm I
keep imagining I got an
arm of an Elm or something.
Everybody in rehab keeps
telling me this is normal;
these are called
phantom limb pains.
Well it may be normal for you
but it's pretty freaking
weird to me man.
Yes, when I came back I
[inaudible] around for weeks
and months, but then my wife she
spoke some truth to me she said,
"mira pendejo, I love you
with one arm or no arm,
but if you don't get off
your ass and start fighting
for your life, I'm
leaving your one arm ass".
And you know what?
She was right, she gave me the
kick in the balls that I needed.
Stopped feeling sorry
for myself,
start to understand how
I can fight and dominate
in this world that
I now lived in.
You see a lot of times we
think that our limitations are
on the outside, pero no,
they're in the inside,
life opens up when you focus
on the possibilities
inside of you --
And you stop making excuses.
[ Music ]
Hey Charlie, you got a light?
I'm not the third one
on the match am I?
Good, because I don't need any
more bad luck I got enough.
Don't be scared Charlie it's
just a short walk over the top.
Once we hear that whistle, we
climb out of these churches
and we tumble over as
rapidly as we can and we run
through the 30 yards
of wire entanglements,
and we zigzag towards our enemy.
It's a beautiful sight Charlie,
when those German shells hit
the ground they shed a fantastic
light upon this earth.
Just imagine a vast
semi-circle of light shelling
up every minute and
burning to 20 or 30 seconds
and then [inaudible]
out like a rocket,
lighting up every man tree
and bush within a half mile.
The flashes in the sky and
the heavy claps of thunder
from the unseen guns
create an amazing spectacle.
It's like the 4th
of July Charlie.
Soon we'll be at home
eating cherry pie.
Hey Charlie, what's your
favorite part of a girl?
Legs? Charlie, every
girl got legs.
Me? Breast.
I love a woman's breast Charlie,
my Mary has these big beauties,
every time I smell her scent
on those letters she writes
me I imagine my head right
in the middle of them.
I kiss my wedding ring
for good luck Charlie,
it brings me back home and
back to my beautiful Mary.
Stand up Charlie, let's go
fight dawn I'll be there
by your side Charlie I promise.
It's a short walk Charlie,
this is our great adventure,
hey Charlie I want
you to know something,
I'm the luckiest
fella in the world
for I know is the true
meaning of what love is,
[ Background noises ]
Hey, you're my [inaudible]
Charlie,
and I'll be with you
every step of the way,
we fight for each other Charlie.
[ Background noises ]
[ Music ]
Dear Sir, the indications are
strong that we shall be moving
in a few days, perhaps tomorrow,
unless I should not be able
to write you again and I feel
compelled to write a few lines
that may fall under your
eyes when I shall be no more.
If it is necessary that I
should fall on the battlefield
to my country, I am ready.
I have no misgivings or lack
of confidence, for the cause
in which I am engaged.
And my coach does not
halter falter [phonetic]
for I know how strong
the American civilization
that leans upon the
triumph of all government.
And the great debt we owe
those who went before us.
Through the blood and sufferings
of the American Revolution
and I am willing, perfectly
willing, to lay down all my joys
in this life to help
maintain this government
and to pay that debt.
So, my love for you is
absolutely deathless
and it seems to find me with
[inaudible], and nothing
but a [inaudible] can break.
But my love my country comes
over me like a strong wind
and bears me irresistibly
on into the battlefield.
I cannot describe to you the
feelings on this column some
of 2000 men sleeping around me,
perhaps enjoying the last
before that of death.
And I suspicious the death
is creeping behind me
with a fatal [inaudible] and
communing with God country
and the, the members of the
blissful moments I have spent
with you come crawling over me
and I am grateful to God and you
that I have enjoyed
it for so long.
And it is hard for me to give
them up and to burn to ash
at the hopes in the future years
when God willing we might
have lived and loved
to see our sons grow
up to be honorable man.
I have few but, small's
claims on Divine Providence.
But something whispers to me,
perhaps is the walking prayers
of my little Edgar
that I shall return
to my loved ones unharmed.
But if I do not Sir, never
forget how much I love you
and when my last breath
escapes me on the battlefield,
I shall whisper your name.
There'll be a soft breeze
pressed upon your cheek,
that should be my spirit
passing by and kissing you.
Do not mourn me Sir, wait for
me, for we shall meet again.
[ Drums ]
My final lesson was brotherhood.
We are we at the
memorial service for Adam,
Adam was struck by an IED and
was killed in Afghanistan.
We had this guy in the battalion
that can play the bagpipes
and our start major found
out so unfortunately for him,
he had to pay the bagpipe
out every memorial we
had in Afghanistan.
But it was a blessing for us
because he was really good
at it, and there's
something extraordinary moving
and beautiful about
the sound of a bagpipe.
And if you're not
Irish or Scottish,
for those brief moments
you kind of wish you were.
Adam had attended ranger school,
and he had been there for 7
or 8 months and he was about
to finish, but he got dropped.
And if anyone knows anything
about the Ranger tag,
it's a pretty coveted
tab to have,
if you get it you can ask
anybody that doesn't have it.
And if you don't get
it well, you get past.
At the memorial service
for Adam everyone
who was Ranger qualified as
they walked by his picture
to say their final goodbyes
and make the final salutes.
They all took off to the
Ranger tag and placed
on the memorial for Adam.
Sort of as a, as a
recognition that he was more
than just another
guy who got killed.
And at that moment you realize
that it's not about you anymore,
it's about your country
but more importantly it's
about the men you serve with.
When I hear taps now I can feel
it, it means something to me.
I realized, I realize
now that I'm part
of an amazing history I'm
part of a brotherhood.
[ Music ]
[ Applauses and Music ]
>> Karen Lloyd: Allow for
some question and answers,
to ask someone has some
questions that they would
like to ask him, Naomi's got a
microphone so we just like you
to pause before you
ask, thoughts,
questions on how he came
up with this major play.
>> Douglas Taurel: It's OK.
>> How did you come up
with this amazing story?
>> Douglas Taurel: Now I
get a mic, I didn't get one
for the show but I, what a day?
So, I, Long story short is,
I have incredible
empathy for the veterans.
So, I started creating letters
about 8 years ago when a lot
of our men and women were coming
back with severe PTSD and a lot
of stories were in the
newspaper especially about guys
who couldn't work
and pay their bills.
That really seem to
pull on my, my strings.
So, I wanted as an artist,
I wanted to do something
to give back, I wanted people
to really understand what
commitment really meant
so I started creating
these letters and,
and I started work shopping.
It you know up front of friends
and this shows changed a lot
from when I started
like seven years ago,
but people kept saying
"you got to keep going,
I think you're on to something".
So, long story short I, I
found the director Patrick,
I don't know he's here and
there is, and I said, "you know,
I got a bunch of
letters from soldiers,
you want to work
on this with me?"
So, I did a monologue for
him and he kind of liked I
and he said "I think we're on to
something" so we put it together
and we kind of created
the show and I kind of,
I finally found the
final structure
that I wanted and
we performed it.
And I've been doing it for two
years now and I've been all
over the country with it.
Last year was at the Kennedy
Center, September I was
in Connecticut, Virginia,
Kansas.
I've been in Texas I've
been all over New York.
It's going to West Point,
it's going to the Citadel.
And it just, people keep asking
me to do it and I love to do it
and I love to share the stories
so, that's kind of, I don't know
if that answers your question,
that's kind of how it
became what it is today.
I hear something.
>> Is there a question
up there or not?
OK, all right, well.
Thank you, and a reminder
that this is based on letters
and stories and I know that
Karen mention the importance
of preserving those
so, sorry, a question?
>> Can you share a little
bit about your history
as an actor, as an artist?
>> Douglas Taurel: Sure.
Well I'm a professional actor,
I've been doing it
for many moons now.
You probably recognize me on
TV I do a lot of, I play a lot
of cop and a lot of
Hitman type roles on TV.
Theater is my passion,
I love it.
I've been doing it in New York
for 20 years now and, but yes,
I mean, I have a movie coming
out with Meghan Gyllenhaal,
"The kindergarten teacher", I
play a cop in there with her.
So, those serious sensibilities
tend to draw me so,
I'm funny when I'm drinking
but I never get cast
as a comedy guy.
And so, but yes, I mean,
not to spit off my resume
but that's who I am as an actor.
But I love the stage,
is for my training.
I've been really blessed to work
with some amazing
theater people.
I work with, I study with Win
Hanuman, he was kind of the,
the, the nucleus of my acting
as an actor here in New York.
He's legendary, he's, he's,
he's worked with everybody
from Dustin Hoffman
to, to Al Pacino.
I mean, who's the
who's of actors,
and his classes were really
great because we always worked
on character and you had to
do a monologue and you had
to create this guy or this
girl or whatever, and,
and you had to find the
dialect in the behavior in the
with everything about them.
So, his training really led me
into this type of work because,
in many ways this
is what I'm doing.
I'm finding out who the
guy is, how does he talk,
how does he walk,
what, what are his his,
his, his speech patterns.
And so, it's character work, so
that's really where my training
and he's Meisner based.
I don't know if anybody else
know anything about acting
but he's very Meisner based.
But yes, that he's pretty
much whom I owe my acting to.
Yes Austin, that's my son.
He asked another question,
what did you say son?
Jesus Christ I'm
going to kill you.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of shows son,
I've been in True West.
>> Karen Lloyd: One
more question and then.
>> Douglas Taurel: Of
Mice and Men first of all.
>> I was going to ask, there
had been like initiatives,
anything to get veterans
into theater maybe as a way
for like therapy for PTSD, have
you thought projects like that?
>> Douglas Taurel:
Yes, there's tons.
I mean, the theaters
become a really powerful,
there's two new forms of
therapy that are starting
to pop up for veterans.
Equestrian, equestrian
therapy with horses,
some really good stuff
with that, and theater.
So, they're getting, there's
project called The Telling
Project and I've been
back and forth with them.
But they do, they do what I do
but they have the veterans
tell their own stories.
They act out their own stories,
and it's been really powerful
for them because it's
allowed them to basic,
the thing with my show
and what veterans need
which is really hard, and
I'm creating a web series
for Thomas Edison Military
Academy based on it.
But they need to talk and
what happens is when you go
into the military your kind
of revved up to be a warrior
and destroy all your
vulnerabilities,
because your vulnerabilities
don't help you
as a soldier in battle.
But when you come back, you
need those vulnerabilities
as a human being to say,
"I'm hurting right now".
But they're so conditioned
to not be vulnerable
that they don't know how to
express themselves anymore,
and that's when the
problem comes because,
they carry all this stuff
inside and they start,
they struggle with it.
And some more than others,
but the ones that can talk
about it tend to seem to
really help themselves.
But therapy, I mean theater
and horse therapy it's
been some two new versions
that have been popping up.
The military is even
looking into the theater
and I did the show in Kansas
for about 300 Vietnam veterans
and afterward we, we have some
great stories but they all said,
"it's so cathartic to hear your
stories because it allows me
to talk about them and it's the
first time that I've been able
to express them" so, but yes.
I mean, just for everybody
to know the only 1%
of our population serve, and
so we put a tremendous amount
of demand on those
guys, men and women.
So, it's just good for
us to remember that 1%
of our population is
our fighting force so.
>> Karen Lloyd: Doug I want
to thank you again, awesome,
and I just learned a quick
commercial that Doug's going
to be back up for Memorial
Day, so I would ask between now
and then you think
about who the veteran
in your life or community is.
And as Doug said they they're
out there, they need to talk,
they don't always
realize they need to talk,
and don't ask them the
hard question just ask them
"wow what was it like?"
Let them come up with the, with
the, with the downside but,
but ask him those questions
about what was the food?
Like what was the best part?
Or perhaps you know, what
were your instructors like?
To get them talking and I
will tell you as a veteran,
I didn't think I had a story and
I had a good interviewer and we,
at The Veterans History Project,
we teach how to interview.
In fact, there's a class
going on right now, and so,
think about reaching out to
The Veterans History Project
to help us teach
you how to interview
so that you can interview
that veteran in your life.
So, again Doug thank
you so much for coming,
I would like to thank everybody
in the audience for coming
as well for making
this just a really.
>> Douglas Taurel: Please share
it on Twitter and Facebook --
>> Karen Lloyd: Yes.
>> Douglas Taurel: Or tag
me and I have a website
for
theamericansoldiersoloshow.com
but use the American
Soldier as a tag.
The more people get out the
more I can keep doing this show,
so don't be lazy
get on social media.
>> Karen Lloyd: All
right [applauses].
Thank you again.
[ Applauses ]
>> This has been a presentation
from The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov